stundenlang geht es in der kleinen
propellermaschine über die schier
endlose kanadischen wälder und tausende
kleiner sehen wir sind unterwegs nach
vorne auf den spuren eines skandals der
die katholische kirche und die
kanadische regierung tief erschüttert
knapp 2000 menschen leben in der
siedlung an der mündung des ernährers an
der hudson bay
die meisten vom stamm der cree first
nation
wir haben uns verabredet mit neo mit
albin er will uns zeigen wo vor 350
jahren alles begann
den ort der ihre welt verändert hat
[Musik]
das hier sind die ruinen der ersten
gebäude der europäer
ich weiß nicht genau ob von der hudson
bay company
oder der kirche den missionaren
1679 kamen die pelz jäger und händler
der hudson bay company hier den norden
kanadas und mit ihm die missionare der
katholischen kirche und die verwandeln
im letzten jahrhundert etwas
flussaufwärts diesen abgelegenen ort für
die ureinwohner und ihre kinder auch für
leo in die hölle auf erden
einige sind noch am leben aber die
meisten haben diese welt mittlerweile
verlassen viele haben es nicht geschafft
zu heilen die region zu werden einige
konnten den schmerz nicht ertragen haben
sich umgebracht oder sind dem alkohol
verfallen
es ist eines der grausamsten kapitel der
kanadischen geschichte eines dass viele
kanadier lieber verdrängen seit 1894
hatte die kanadische regierung im ganzen
land ein netzwerk so genannter indien
residenzen schools aufgebaut internate
in denen die kinder der ureinwohner von
ihrer religion und eigenen sprache
isoliert und in die europäische kultur
assimiliert werden sollten in den
schulbetrieb übertrug die regierung an
die kirchen doch was die den kindern oft
an taten wenn die nicht gehorchten hatte
nichts mit der verkündung der
christlichen botschaft zu tun
sie mussten mit dem gesicht zur wand
stehen und dann haben sie sie vor uns
allen ausgeprägt
die die ganz vorne standen konnten sehen
wie das blut an die wand gespritzt
sie haben dieses trauma diesen schmerz
mitgenommen als sie mit der schule
fertig war
er selbst sei durch die schule zu einem
monster geworden erzählt uns leo auf dem
weg zu seinem bruder aber er sei anders
als viele andere geheilt worden durch
das leben in der einsamkeit der
kanadischen wildnis
leer und sein bruder edmund waren
schüler deshalb ins internat hier in
port alberni betrieben von der
katholischen kirche seit jahrzehnten
versuchen sie über die verbrechen der
kirchlichen würdenträger aufzuklären
lange wollte ihn niemand glauben für die
einen waren ist die lügen der wilden für
die andere zu monströs die
menschenverachtende brutalität
wir mussten unser eigenes erbrochenes
essen wenn wir krank waren und nicht
aufessen konnten sie haben das
erbrochene aufgehoben wir mussten es
dann essen wenn es uns wieder bessert
und dann war da der elektrische stuhl
wir mussten uns reinsetzen er war aus
metall sie haben uns gesagt wir müssen
uns daran festhalten und dann haben sie
den strom eingeschaltet
wir waren vielleicht sechs sieben jahre
alt in der strom kommt kannst du nicht
mehr loslassen weil sich alles
verkrampft wir wurden unter strom
gesetzt wir waren nur kinder
[Musik]
und nachts habe sich für die kinder das
tor zur hölle geöffnet erzählt edmund
wenn die sonne unterging dann kamen die
pädophile die nonnen sind in die
schlafräume gegangen und haben ein kind
ein mädchen für den bischof abgeholt der
private religiöse instruktion
[Musik]
wenn aber der bischof so etwas den
kindern antun kann was glaubst du tut an
der rest der brüder und schwestern
es wurde normal und zügellos
schwester francois und mutters opera
haben sich das gleiche kind mit aufs
zimmer genommen bruder bui hat das
gleiche mädchen immer und immer wieder
attackiert und vater war war ein serien
pädophiler
das ist mittlerweile durch viele
aussagen bestätigt
manchmal wurden die mädchen schwanger an
einen fall kann sich edmund besonders
gut erinnern
sie haben sie abgeholt und in die
krankenstation gebracht und das kind
abgetrieben
im siebten oder achten monat
folter vergewaltigung zwangsabtreibungen
es ist das pure böse dem die kinder im
katholischen st 1 begegnet in den 90er
jahren beginnt edmund beweise und
zeugenaussagen für die verbrechen
zusammenzutragen und übergibt sie der
polizeibehörde von terium die ermittelt
vier jahre schließlich werden fünf
angestellte zu kurzen haftstrafen meist
auf bewährung verurteilt keiner der
würdenträger ist darunter der inhalt des
ermittlungsbericht wird bis heute von
der kanadischen regierung geheim
gehalten die rechtsanwältin fading die
die interessen der opfer vertritt
spricht von einem skandal
der große skandal ist die vertuschung
die vertuschung von kindesmissbrauch
wer ist da alles involviert und wie tief
geht das es geht hier nicht nur um den
ermittlungsbericht der polizei
der kanadische sender cbc konnte
beweisen dass alle schul dokumente nach
rom gebracht wurden die katholische
kirche hat das bestätigt und das obwohl
die kirche sich verpflichtet hatte die
dokumente an die opfer und ihre anwälte
zu übergeben sie unterliegen kanadischem
recht wie kann es also sein dass ihre
dokumente aus kanada nach rom geschickt
werden
1976 zieht sich die kirche aus der
schule in fort herbern ii zurück 2002
geht das ehemalige internat aus
ungeklärten gründen in flammen auf er
hat man zeigt uns wo die schule früher
einmal stand das fundament eines
nebengebäudes ist alles was von dem
horror seiner kindheit übrig geblieben
ist und wir fragen ihn noch was er vom
besuch des papstes jetzt in kanada
erwartet
es ist ein gutes fundraising gimmick der
kirche gehen die gläubigen aus das geld
ihre infrastruktur ihre gebäude sie
müssen also etwas tun
das ist für sie ganz praktisch aber uns
wird es nicht helfen
und jetzt das
für seinen bruder leo gibt es nur die
natur die helfen kann die reiniger sich
selbst und heile alte wunden und er
bahnt sich seinen weg über die gräber
der missionare mittlerweile vom
bärenklau überwuchert sind